bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition du 7 8
week-end nous allons revenir comme tous
les vendredis sur les moments forts de
l'actualité culture loisirs et sport de
la semaine pendant 26 minutes au cours
de cette émission nous vous ferons
découvrir avec Sylvie launa à la
directrice
diveline tourisme des idées d'activité
pour petits et grands pour la seconde
semaine des vacances de la Toussaint
mais tout d'abord c'est actuellement la
saison de la cueillette des champignons
et dans la forêt de Rambouillet les
mycologues ont recensé plus de 2000
variétés le week-end dernier à Gazeran
se tenait une exposition pour en
apprendre un peu plus sur la toxicité
des champignons Olivier Maniscalco vous
explique tout
apprendre à cueillir sans danger les
champignons c'est le thème que proposait
ce week-end l'exposition mycologique de
Gazeran organisé depuis plusieurs années
par le Centre d'études de Rambouillet et
de sa forêt l'expo proposé aux visiteurs
d'observer près de 220 espèces de
champignons
de Bordeaux chanterelle en tube ou
trompette de la mort certains
champignons se consomment sans risque
pour d'autres il faut être bien plus
vigilant le Conseil déjà qu'on va donner
en premier c'est de bien cueillir
l'intégralité du champignon parce que si
on n'a pas les caractéristiques de la
bosse du pied on peut passer à côté
d'une amanite avec une volve donc bien
cueillir l'intégralité du champignon
alors voilà donc la manif halloïde qu'il
faut bien apprendre à connaître puisque
c'est vraiment la plus dangereuse avec
une volve en sac très épaisse un anneau
et surtout elle est verdâtre avec des
fibris sur le chapeau mais elle peut
aussi être blanche donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut bien cueillir tout le
champignon pour avoir la Golf
un tout petit bout la moitié du chapeau
là ça peut vous tuer
je ne cueille pas plus de champignons en
fait parce que depuis trois ans que je
découvert cette cette exposition je
trouve qu'il y a beaucoup de champignons
qui se ressemblent trop et donc j'ai
peur de me tromper si je ne suis pas
accompagné par quelqu'un de compétence
près de 2000 variétés de champignons ont
été inventoriés sur le massif de
Rambouillet selon le cerf les cas
d’intoxication sont en augmentation ces
derniers temps prenez donc le temps de
vous renseigner ou de faire appel à un
mycologue avant vos sorties en forêt
je le disais dans les titres la première
semaine de des vacances de la Toussaint
se termine et si vous n'avez pas encore
trouvé une activité pour vos enfants
Sylvie launa la directrice d'Yvelines
tourisme va nous donner quelques bons
plans bonjour à vous Sylvie alors tout
d'abord je crois qu'on va partir du côté
du musée du jouet à Poissy voilà alors
là ce sont des ateliers qu'on propose
aux enfants c'est sur inscription et
dans le cadre de jeux de construction
l'exposition qui est monté au musée du
jouet à Poissy on peut fabriquer
des maisons en boîte d'allumettes ou une
maison de poupées à l'intérieur d'une
boîte de chaussures et puis on peut
jouer aussi aux architectes d'intérieur
donc tout ça à Poissy au Musée du Jouet
on va rester peut-être un petit peu dans
l'architecture et la culture au chaton
de maison au château de Maisons-Laffitte
exactement donc c'est le même style
effectivement c'est une exposition qui
s'appelle
architecte et jeu de construction donc
comme chacun sait le château de
Maisons-Laffitte a été conçu par
François Mansart et donne on donne des
petits livrets aux jeunes qui viennent
pratiquer cet atelier ils peuvent
s'inspirer de cette de cette étonnant
architecte François Mansart pour créer
eux-mêmes leurs propres construction et
si vos enfants ne sont pas tentés par
l'architecture et la culture il y a une
activité assez originale du côté de la
Bergerie Nationale alors là c'est
beaucoup plus ludique c'est on est plus
du tout dans la construction n'est plus
dans l'aspect culturel on est vraiment
dans le jeu et c'est donc à la Bergerie
Nationale à Rambouillet donc on peut
jouer aux Indiens et au cow-boy donc on
peut être accueilli par les cowboys dans
le ranch
s'exercer au lasso
s'exercer au fer à cheval au lancer de
faire un cheval ou rodéo sur un cheval
mécanique donc plein plein de choses qui
ont trait à la vie du cow-boy et puis on
peut être aussi accueilli par les
Indiens dans leur tipi et là on apprend
à fabriquer un arc et des flèches et
puis on apprend à réaliser le bandeau
d'Indiens on mange des châtaignes plein
d'activités
mais il faut pas surtout pas oublier que
on peut aussi voir les animaux comme
d'habitude à la bergerie et voir un peu
comme on s'en occupe et même y
participer si on le souhaite donc un bon
moment de jeu pour les enfants à la
bergerie un autre lieu de culture il y
en a quand même beaucoup dans le
département cette fois-ci du côté de
Mantes-la-Jolie alors à Mantes-la-Jolie
à côté de la collégiale il y a un musée
qui s'appelle le musée de l'hôtel yo il
y a une exposition là actuellement sur
Dali et le surréalisme alors comme ça ça
a pas l'air très ludique mais finalement
on le rend ludique pour les enfants et
on leur propose de regarder un peu
comment faisait les surréalistes et le
courant de Max
Ernst de Joan Miro et on leur montre
comment on peut réaliser avec des
feutres avec du collage ou des peintures
un tableau surréaliste donc on le rendu
serait peut-être pas la première venue
dans l'esprit des enfants je pense
qu'ils penserait plutôt à la bergerie
dans leur esprit mais c'est intéressant
et c'est c'est rigolo finalement même si
le sujet au départ ne l'est pas quelques
balades presque traditionnelles du côté
de France Miniature voilà pour les pour
les vacances d'automne on découvre
France Miniature aux couleurs de
l'automne et c'est extrêmement joli de
voir la France en miniature avec des
couleurs un peu spécifiques il y a des
balades comté et donc la conteuse emmène
les enfants
auprès des des miniatures et leur fait
découvrir des légendes des comptes et
tout un tas d'histoires qui vont les
faire frémir on est quand même aux
abords d'Halloween il faut pas l'oublier
oui j'allais venir halloween c'est dans
quelques jours si vous n'avez pas encore
votre déguisement vous allez pouvoir le
préparer en tout cas voilà et on peut
aller à la ferme de Villepin pour faire
de la sculpture sur citrouille donc on
achète sa citrouille et on la sculpte
évidemment selon son gré on fait un peu
ce qu'on veut et c'est une activité tout
à fait ludique on repart avec son futur
déguisement pour halloween halloween
aussi du côté du château de Thoiry dans
quelques jours alors un château
évidemment il y a tout un tas d'ancêtres
et de et de fantômes qui peuvent
peut-être
régner sur les différentes pièces alors
on va les rencontrer et de vampires vous
accueillent et puis là on vous fait
rencontrer les fantômes et toutes ces
créatures qui font peur et puis il y a
un parcours spécifique avec des
anecdotes et tout ce genre de choses
spécifiquement pour Halloween mais bien
sûr faut pas oublier quand même qu'on
peut même rencontrer les araignées les
petits insectes à l'arche des petites
bêtes qui a été ouvert l'année dernière
donc tous ces les animaux tout petit qui
sont qui ont été recensés dans cette
dans cet arche et donc une bonne journée
en perspective à Thoiry après le château
hanté de Thoiry on va peut-être aussi
pouvoir fêter Halloween dans les airs
alors la dit comme ça ça laisse rêveur
et c'est la chronique spéciale Halloween
qui peut se faire le 31 octobre prochain
à la base de loisirs de Saint-Quentin
donc l'association branche et Loisirs
vous propose de faire une activité
spéciale Halloween le soir donc avec des
des peintures fluorescentes et donc on
vous voit la nuit vous pouvez même vous
déguiser et donc c'est encore plus
impressionnant que la journée on se
jette dans les airs et on voit pas
vraiment où on se jette mais c'est
sécurisé on ne risque rien évidemment
mais ça fait peur merci beaucoup Sylvie
pour toutes ces idées de sortie donc
pour la deuxième semaine des vacances de
la Toussaint et puis à bientôt pour de
nouvelles idées bons plans à bientôt
cette semaine dans le kiosque Nicolas
Gervais vous a fait découvrir
Ubu Roi mise en scène par des clans
cette pièce de théâtre fera étape au
théâtre Saint-Quentin de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines du 6 au 9
novembre prochain rencontre avec l'un
des acteurs Sylvain Levitte
c'est l'histoire de pérubu et merubu qui
veulent accéder au pouvoir
mes rubis incitent perubus a tué le
roiens et apprendre le trône et à partir
du moment où il devient roi et va se
mettre à tuer tous les nobles tous les
magistrats tous les financiers de son
royaume ça c'est la version jarrhée
Jarry a écrit donc en étant adolescent
et il a écrit cette pièce directement en
référence à son professeur de physique
monsieur Hébert
et il a il a fait une caricature
grossière de son professeur de physique
et pour ça
et mon patron à physique
et mon casque à finance et mon troc à
finance
a pris vraiment au pied de la lettre
l'esprit de la pièce de Jarry c'est à
dire qu'il s'est vraiment dit il s'est
vraiment mis dans l'esprit de Jarry et
d'essayer de construire une pièce qui
réponde directement à l'envie d'Alfred
Jarry au moment où elle a été écrite
donc comme je disais tout à l'heure
c'était vraiment une une caricature et
une provocation vis-à-vis du monde
adulte vis-à-vis du monde donc de son
professeur de physique
et donc il s'est emparé véritablement de
de cette pièce en la mettant aujourd'hui
dans un appartement parisien bourgeois
et il regarde toute la pièce de Jarry à
travers le regard d'un adolescent donc
c'est moi qui interprète cette
adolescent là
il regarde toute la pièce de Jarry à
travers ce point de vue là
comme si cette adolescent qui est donc
du coup par métaphore un peu Alfred
Jarry
ce moque et dévoile
le véritable comportement de ses parents
le véritable comportement qu'on peut
tout savoir
peut-être dans une chambre et à mon âge
frère
des comportements qu'on a tous le désir
de pouvoir l'image qu'on a en public
n'est pas l'image qu'on a en privé aussi
et même pour soi-même parfois mais c'est
profondément humain
cette mise en scène là est profondément
humaine et humaine dans toutes ses
contradictions c'est à dire que on cache
en permanence des désirs de pouvoir de
pouvoir absolu à travers ce masque de la
civilisation des clans donnait l'âme
dans les répétitions nous a dit qu'on a
tous un Ubu en nous on a tous on a tous
des désirs de pouvoir on a tous des
désirs de meurtre plus ou moins assumé
là cet adolescent fait passer à l'acte
dévoile cette chose là et révèle non pas
la véritable identité mais ce qu'on a
tous en nous qu'on cache
celui-ci
depuis combien de temps
Laurent Bidot et l'auteur du premier
tome de paradoxe édité par gna BD
d'anticipation en fait qui met en scène
la découverte du voyage à travers le
temps par un prix Nobel de Supra
physique installé à Versailles le
dessinateur travaille sur le second
volet le second tome de ce triptyque il
nous a ouvert les portes de son atelier
nous sommes en compagnie d'un
dessinateur aujourd'hui Laurent Bidault
à Versailles les dessinateur de cette
bande dessinée paradoxe édité par gléna
scénarisé par Didier qu'on va bonjour
merci de nous recevoir chez vous dans
votre atelier c'est ici que vous
travaillez paradoxe premier tome qui
vient de sortir en librairie c'est de la
science-fiction 2034 à edvil Conrad un
homme qui est capable de voyager entre
des univers parallèles vous pouvez nous
en dire un petit peu plus sur cette
histoire et c'est une histoire
effectivement de science-fiction mais
avec une grande part du récit qui se
situe aujourd'hui et duel Conrad et en
fait diplômée du supravitique on va même
dire prix Nobel de Supra physique mais
il est très controversé et effectivement
il a la capacité de se déplacer dans le
temps mais de se cloner en fait dans le
temps et le tout pour sauver sa femme en
fait il veut présenter comme un ouvrage
d'anticipation c'est à dire que vous y
croyez c'est possibilité ces évolutions
c'est basé aussi sur une sur une
histoire vraie sur une expérience vraie
un petit peu qui avait permis à des
scientifiques de
laisser la vitesse de la lumière en tout
cas c'est ce qu'il pensait ça a été
ensuite contredit l'année suivante en
2012 mais en 2011 on y croyait c'est ça
qui a lancé l'histoire effectivement oui
c'est l'idée de départ de pour le
scénariste ça lui a permis de se dire
tiens et si on se déplaçant dans le
temps on laissait une un double de
soi-même à cet endroit là mais
effectivement ça permet d'avoir un
scénario extrêmement
malin intelligent et retord justement on
s'est retour c'est compliqué comme comme
scénario est-ce que du coup ça rend
compliqué l'illustration les dessins
parce qu'il faut rester aussi fluide
pour la compréhension du lecteur on
voyage entre les époques on voit ce
personnage parfois se rencontrer
lui-même aussi donc il faut faire
attention à la façon dont il vieillit
pour que ça reste crédible il y a
énormément de difficultés dans cette
bande dessinée parce qu'il faut à la
fois effectivement être clair donc j'ai
utilisé un style training clair et
effectivement faire attention à tous les
détails tous les raccords il faut que
les personnages on les voit vieillir on
les sent vieillir et que les vêtements
aussi expriment des changements d'époque
des changements de style très précis
vous travaillez plus techniquement
peut-être vous dessinez tout ici vous
revenez ensuite vous travaillez par
ordinateur comment ça se passe votre
travail de dessinateur il y a un peu des
deux j'ai aussi fait des reportages sur
place puisqu'il y a le Lutetia dans le
tome 1 qui est qui apparaît il y a aussi
différents quartiers de Paris que j'ai
voulu voir précisément pour préparer le
travail vous faites des croquis de
photos surtout donc des photos reportage
pour
visualiser géographique proprement les
lieux et ensuite oui je dessine ici
d'abord un premier storyboard qui permet
de mettre en place les cases et les
personnages dans les cases puis ensuite
un long travail de dessin ensuite ces
dessins sont scannés sur ordinateur
intégrer dans la mise en page
ensuite on crée et ensuite mis en couple
on parlez de la ligne au clair d'un
décentrées lignes au clair en ce qui
concerne cette bande dessinée votre
travail et ce qui vous inspire justement
comme comme auteur comme classique de la
BD franco-belge est-ce qu'il y a des
auteurs qui qui ont guidé un petit peu
vos débuts de dessinateurs et aux
inspire
disons que oui les grands classiques moi
j'aime beaucoup William vente il décide
qui dessine 13 il a un style très
efficace très épuré mais plein plein
d'énergie
enfin j'aimais beaucoup les Tuniques
Bleues que
certainement un moment donné envie de
faire la bande dessinée donc c'est assez
éloigné de ce que je fais aujourd'hui
mais sont des bandes dessinées
classiques franco-belge plein de
d'énergie et plein de qualité
pendant les vacances de la Toussaint
l'estaminet de manière mot accueil la
fête des morts qui nous vient tout droit
du Mexique à l'époque des Aztèques cette
fête célébrait les retrouvailles des
morts et des vivants et pour l'occasion
les enfants peuvent construire leur
Calaveras comprenait leur tête de mort
Olivier Maniscalco a découvert leur
création
pour la Toussaint l'estaminet de Manille
les amours en hommage à ses morts à la
mode mexicaine traditionnelle en
Amérique centrale la fête des morts
célèbre en famille les ancêtres disparus
malgré son nom c'est une fête joyeuse
les mariachi viennent jouer de la
musique dans les maisons décorées de
fleurs et on revait au squelette leur
plus beaux habits on colore aussi des
têtes de mort comme ce matin dans cet
atelier où les enfants se montrent
créatifs avec leur crâne en terre cuite
en blanc après je vais je vais faire une
bouche jaune
et des motifs orange et bleu c'est une
initiative qui a été prise par
l'estaminet de célébrer la fête des
morts un peu autrement et de donner une
connotation avec une autre accès à une
autre culture qui était la culture
mexicaine il y a une exposition Frida
Kahlo en ce moment à Paris et donc on
avait aussi envie de faire un lien par
rapport à ça ouvrir un peu les gens ici
sur une autre dimension culturelle que
la dimension toujours Halloween habituel
quoi jusqu'à vendredi les enfants auront
l'occasion de découvrir cette fête
méconnue via d'autres ateliers créatifs
crâne en sucre pain des morts et
projections
viendront agrémenter leur culture
mexicaine
et évidemment vous pourrez admirer
toutes ces œuvres d'art à l'estaminet on
vous y rendant à Manille et un mot dans
les prochains jours nous allons
continuer de voyager cette fois-ci aux
Caraïbes en Afrique ou encore au Brésil
pendant deux jours les jeunes verriers
rois se sont initiés aux instruments de
percussion comme le djembé ou le style
drum violent Torres a subi l'un des
cours
voyage au 4 coins du monde à La Verrière
durant deux jours l'espace aimer ses
heures accueille des enfants de 7 à 15
ans pour des ateliers percussions au
programme la batucada ce genre de
musique brésilien proche de la samba se
joue avec des instruments utilisés lors
des carnavals
dans un tout autre style à quelques
mètres de là certains s'initient à la
tradition africaine du djembé
retour dans les années 20 aux Caraïbes
ici on joue du style drum Asian et
j'explique l'histoire de cet instrument
l'un des seuls exemples de révolution
par la musique les Anglais ils ont
envahi les îles et que les habitants ils
ont été tous tués et ceux qui étaient en
esclavage ils pouvaient plus faire de
musique alors ils ont trouvé des bidons
et ils ont ils ont cabossé ça fait ben
cet instrument maintenant
cet instrument fabriqué à partir de
bidons de pétrole est accessible à tous
et ne nécessite aucune connaissance
musicale l'enseignement est oral on n'a
pas de partition rien du tout les notes
sont indiquées sur les instruments et
puis voilà c'est la mémoire qui va
travailler et puis
l'apprentissage de l'oreille directement
il y a pas de partition et c'est entre
celui qui guide le professeur et puis
les élèves qui vont qui vont se servir
de
aussi de leur propre moyen des camarades
et puis essayer à chaque fois d'avoir
quelque chose de cohérent
avant de passer au sport à un petit
appel à photo le Conseil général des
Yvelines vous invite à participer à la
grande collecte une opération nationale
pour commémorer la Première Guerre
mondiale alors si vous avez encore dans
vos albums des clichés de la Grande
Guerre rendez-vous aux archives
départementales à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
en baseball les cougars sont passés à
deux petits points du titre de champion
de France junior face au Paris
Université Club le week-end dernier pas
pourtant tout avait bien débuté en
demi-finale face au squale de Vauréal
récit de ce weekend
dans cette demi-finale face à Vauréal
les inhymontins sont mis sur orbite par
leur lanceur Frédéric Walter réussi
l’exploit de réaliser 10 retraits en
l'espace de quatre manches avec en prime
un au haters sur sa prestation de quoi
ouvrir le boulevard pour les frappeurs
et notamment Yuki dès son premier
passage à la batte le jeune cougar en
flamme Jean maréchal derrière lui les
inhy montants en chêne les points pour
mener après quatre manches 13 zéro au
bout de cinq manches la messe édite 21-6
les cougars s'envolent vers la finale
c'est impressionnant mais c'était pas
gagné puisque au tour préliminaire cette
équipe même équipe nous avait mis 14-1
quand même on l'avait je pense que le
premier match retour préliminaire on
l'avait pas pris au sérieux enfin en
tout cas pas assez au sérieux et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on a on a fait le
nécessaire pour que on est arrivé on
voulait on voulait on avait un petit
esprit de revanche et il fallait leur
mettre un gros score parce que voilà on
voulait la finale et en plus on avait
cette petite esprit on avait pris une
fessée on voulait pas on voulait pas
reprendre une deuxième le dimanche les
joueurs de Rodolphe le meurt sont
opposés aux vices champion de France
2012 pari Université Club après les deux
premières manches Montigny ne mène que
d'un petit point grâce à la pépite Yuki
ensuite les lanceurs neutralisent les
frappeurs jusqu'à la 6e manche le plus
qu'inscrit alors les 5 points du titre
de l'année deux dernières rotations le
rêve ini monte impasse et cela fait 6
ans que cela dure mais l'avenir est
prometteur et les 5 continents pourront
tout de même se consoler avec Yuki et
Fred Walter et lui respectivement
meilleur frappeur et meilleur joueur des
finales il s'appelle Xavier benner il a
31 ans et partage sa vie entre les
terrains de volley-ball et le
Technocentre de Guyancourt il est
capitaine de l'équipe de France de
volley-ball mais des sourds depuis près
de 10 ans ce 50 ninois redaurer tout à
fait le le blason du volley-ball
français nous l'avons rencontré avec
Jonathan Wilman
Xavier devient sourd à l'âge d'un an à
la suite d'une méningite s'il parle
c'est grâce à des années de travail avec
des orthophonistes il peut nous
comprendre car il a appris à lire sur
les lèvres ma famille mes parents ont
bien pris en compte
c'est normal comme un autre à 14 ans il
claque ses premiers smashs avec les
balides à Amiens Xavier découvre alors
le volet des sourds et de nouveaux
repères sur le terrain
au début des années 2000 l'équipe de
France est l'être morte 7 ans plus tard
il décide de la remettre sur pied en
2011 la sélection finisse 6e des
championnats d'Europe puis à nouveau 6e
au mondiaux l'année suivante malgré ces
bons résultats les volleyeurs tricolores
ne sont pas médiatisés mais cela ne
dérange pas le Guyancourtois
Jeux olympiques
de Renault depuis 2005 il travaille
actuellement sur les moteurs électriques
de la marque au Technocentre Xavier
communic grâce à un outil de discussion
par webcam avec l'aide d'un interprète
qui retranscrit la discussion en langue
des signes quand il n'est pas au bureau
il joue en championnat de France des
sourds avec le stade parisien club qu'il
a lui-même créé et Xavier continue
d'affronter les valides au niveau
départemental son dernier objectif sur
le terrain monter sur les podiums des
championnats d'Europe à Paris en 2015
avant de refermer ce 7 8 week-end
évidemment place à votre agenda culturel
et sportif pour ces deux prochains jours
tout d'abord une exposition d'art
Armanet c'est la 11e édition
l'exposition se tient à la Ferme du
Manet à Montigny-le-Bretonneux vous
pourrez découvrir des peintures ou des
sculptures tout le week-end et même et
lire votre coup de cœur en sport c'est
du roller ok coup de Coupe de France les
chocs entre dans la compétition face au
Patriote de l'île rendez-vous au gymnase
chastagnier d'Élancourt coup d'envoi à
13h ce dimanche et donc ce que votre
émission culture la semaine prochaine
Aurélia Debussy vous délivrera tous les
secrets pour fêter Halloween comme il se
doit quant à moi je vous retrouverai
évidemment dans le 7 8 sport avec la
toute nouvelle section féminine féminine
des Templiers d'Élancourt et n'oubliez
pas ce week-end dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche nous passons à l'heure d'hiver
à 3h du matin il sera deux heures vous
devez donc reculer vos horloges et
toutes vos montres et bien sûr on gagne
une heure de sommeil d'ici là excellent
weekend sur téléfilm